- The biggest excuse in the world,
the duchiest excuse in the world,
the worst excuse in the world is--
(dramatic music)
You got your perspective.
(audience cheering)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
- [Announcer] Please give
it up for Gary Vaynerchuk!
(audience cheering)
- [Gary] Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
- [Audience] Gary, Gary!
- Just wanna make sure my mic's on.
You can keep chanting my name if you want.
- [Audience] Gary!
- I'm just kidding.
Can you guys here me?
Hello hello hello hello?
Good, no, no?
No, there we go, I hear a little more.
Little more, little more,
little more, that's good.
What is up Singapore?
(audience cheering)
Thank you for the warm intro.
All right, lot of things
I wanna cover today.
Feel free to sit down,
unless you wanna stand.
You do you.
You know, I flew from
Malaysia this morning,
and I was thinking about
what I wanted to speak about,
with this incredible crowd,
and there was a lot of different things
running through my mind.
But I broke them down
into a couple places.
I think one of the things
that I'm very fearful of,
is hypocrisy.
I think it really sucks when people talk
out of both sides of their mouth,
and I think one of the things,
that when I was growing
up in the business world
that became apparent to me,
is why do people take
advice from individuals
who've never done something?
Right?
I've spent a lot of time
thinking about that.
Now, it's a very interesting
thing in my mind,
because I used to be very 100% about this,
which is don't listen to anybody
who's never done something.
But then I realized that
some of the best coaches
in sports history never played the game,
but understood how to give advice.
So that kind of took a step back.
But the thing that I've realized,
was the reason that my initial reaction
was don't listen to anybody
who's never done it,
was that for me, when I communicate,
I'm incapable of being the kind of coach
for a football team if I never played it.
I would never be good at that.
Had I played baseball,
or football, or Jai-Alai
or whatever it may be,
I would have then been
able to give advice.
But if not, I couldn't watch film
or study the game and give advice.
Going through this self-awareness
over the last 20 years,
has allowed me to think
about why, over the
last two or three years,
my content continues to
resonate even more than ever,
it's because I'm getting even more narrow
in what I talk about.
One of my favorite comments
on my YouTube channel
or my podcasts or my
Instagram or LinkedIn,
is when somebody says Gary
V, you're getting boring.
You say the same shit.
(audience laughing)
I go, that's the point.
If you really understand the process,
I think there's way too many people
talking about stuff they don't understand
or, because they think
it will do well for them.
I only wanna talk about the
stuff that I understand,
'cause it's the only way
I can bring any value.
And I'm fine if somebody
feels like they got it.
I think, how many people
here have watched my vlog?
Raise your hand.
Thank you.
So I think you guys know, on the vlog,
every 20, 30 episodes, 50 episodes,
I get weird and look at the camera
and say what the fuck are
you still watching this for?
(audience laughing)
And I think, when I think of myself,
in the personalities
that speak or write books
or put content, I feel
like I'm the reverse.
I want people to hear me for free,
and then go on and do their thing and win,
instead of keeping people in my funnel
and monetize them through
courses or masterminds
or other things.
I think that's important,
and I'll tell you why.
I think that it's super important
to watch who you take advice from.
I always am fascinated
when people are like,
Gary, I've been watching
your business videos,
like a friend, forget about,
you know, somebody I've
known for 25 years.
They're like Gary, I've been
watching your stuff lately,
but, my uncle tells me I should do this.
And the first question I always ask is,
and the person's asking
a business question,
and I ask them, well
tell me about your uncle.
And they're like, well he's a gym teacher
at our high school.
I'm like well, if you
want to be a gym teacher,
your uncle is a tremendous
person to listen to,
but if you wanna build a business,
I think I'm better at building
businesses than your uncle.
And so, the reason I
start this talk this way
is 'cause I think I have a
little bit or a curve ball
for people that have been
following me for a little while.
I think a lot of your know
that one of the things
I fear the most, fear,
is I don't want to be
a motivational speaker.
I don't like that at all.
I mean it, I don't like it at all,
because I don't think of myself that way.
But over the last year and a half,
the reason I put out content
that may be more rah-rah
or things of that nature,
is 'cause I've realized, my god,
my greatest strength,
the thing that I realize
I can give best advice on,
is I'm the byproduct
of very good parenting,
very good environment,
which means I didn't grow up with much,
so I'm not entitled,
very tried and true 20 years
of business, at this point,
based on work ethic
and based on giving value to the customer
over anything else.
And I realized that if you're
here on a beautiful Saturday
in the summer for this
talk, that we have to start
in the strategy of where your head's at,
and then I can talk to you about the fact,
and this is just true, there's a reason,
I don't know if you guys know this,
but VaynerMedia is opening
an office in Singapore
in the first quarter of next year, right?
(audience cheering)
So, I'm gonna be here a
lot more going forward
over the next five years.
So if you see me in a restaurant,
don't just stare at me,
come over and say hello.
But, I think that the
thing that's on my mind
in this market is mindset.
I can give you the reasons
we're opening an office in Singapore,
because in southeast Asia,
my marketing strategies
of buying Facebook ads,
running ads with KOLs,
and giving them as much money as possible,
doing podcast and LinkedIn content,
works better in Singapore
and Malaysia and Indonesia
than it does in America or Europe.
So, all the propaganda that I push
around Facebook advertising
and Instagram and all that,
I promise you, whether you're a lawyer,
or you have an app startup,
or you wanna sell t-shirts,
I don't understand why anyone's confused.
The only practical advice
I have for you right now,
practical, black and white,
is run more ads on social media.
And, if you're going to run
more ads on social media
to do whatever you're trying to sell,
your course, your
sneakers, your real estate,
whatever you do,
there's one part that
breaks in running more ads
on social media,
do you know how to put
a good picture or video
or written word in the ad?
The variable of running great
ads, is the creative itself.
And I think too many people
don't respect the art enough,
they just respect the math.
But from a practical standpoint,
everybody here should be
running a lot more social media.
Nobody here is taking it serious enough.
I'll tell you why.
I take it more serious
than my own religion,
and I don't take it serious enough.
So, if I'm up here and I
don't take it serious enough,
there is nobody here that is taking
how big of an opportunity
this is, serious enough.
I will go back to tactics in a minute,
but let me tell you why I started my talk
on what am I best at?
And that should be my advice.
What I'm best at is knowing
that the far majority
of people in this room right now,
have not achieved the success
or happiness they're looking for,
mainly on the back of the fact
that they value their mother
or father's opinion too much.
The thing that I understand about life
and then that matters in business,
is you either listen to your own voice,
or you listen to somebody else's.
The thing that people need to
understand more than anything,
is what is driving their ambition?
Why are you doing what you're doing?
What are you trying to scratch?
What itch are you trying to scratch?
Are you trying to be successful
to prove to people that said you wouldn't?
because you love the process?
Are you doing it because you
wanna buy something fancy
to show people that you're successful?
Why do you do what you're doing?
And most of all, for who?
What happened to me,
through very good parenting,
is I played for myself.
How many people say Rocky IV?
The one in Russia, raise your hands,
I wanna just get a sense.
Raise it high if you saw that movie.
Good, good amount.
In Rocky IV, he fights
a Russian guy, Rocky.
The Russian guy talks about the pressure
of the whole Soviet Union
wanting him to beat Rocky,
and at one point he cracks,
and tells the Russian
government and all the fans,
fuck you, I'm not fighting
for you, I'm fighting for me.
I've always thought about
that scene my whole life,
and I didn't know why until
about two or three years ago,
which I realized oh my
god, I'm living for me.
I'm playing this game for me.
Not for anybody else.
And everybody else is
playing for somebody else.
And that was unbelievably liberating,
and I'll be very honest with you,
I was very grateful for that.
I think a lot of people in this room
have to go home tonight and ask themselves
who they're playing for?
Making your parents proud
is usually the first step to disaster.
I mean it.
I understand that it's a interesting angle
to talk about this,
it's great to want to
make your parents proud,
but not at the expense of your happiness.
And so, I've become
unbelievably fascinated
with the mindset of why people do stuff,
and why am I able to work 17 hours a day?
I'm able to work 17 hours
a day 'cause I love it.
Nobody works 17 hours a day
'cause of any other thing
because they love it.
All the people that try to
teach you how to get rich
with the least amount of
work, they love the money.
They love the money.
People love the money.
A lot of people here are
here to figure out the secret
for the money.
You love the money, you value the money.
I don't value the money, I value the game.
My game is how good am I at this?
I value the admiration.
That's a tough thing to say a little bit,
'cause it seems kinda
shallow, but it's my truth.
I was so over loved by my mother,
that when I went into the real world,
I still wanted the love.
And I basically manifested
with my DNA and my environment
in a way that I,
there's only one reason
that I'm giving you
more value than most people,
it's because I want your admiration.
And the only way to get real admiration,
is to give the most.
Simple as that.
It's not super complicated.
So I'm spending a lot of time
trying to figure out
what the fuck am I doing?
What the fuck am I doing in
Singapore on Saturday right now?
And I realize, you better
be doing the same thing.
Because when you start
figuring out that shit,
everything starts becoming a lot easier.
And listen, one of the biggest reasons
I'm unbelievably drawn to southeast Asia,
is because of entrepreneurship DNA, right?
There's a rawness to the entrepreneurs
in the southeast Asian market
that I really am attracted to,
because I think I share that
kinship in a lot of ways.
But I'll be honest with you,
probably right there with it,
and as I get older every
day, maybe even more so,
I'm fascinated by the parenting
culture in southeast Asia,
and the obnoxious mistakes
that are being made
by parents treating their
children as products,
which I see playing out in America,
but it's way more fucked up here.
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
But before all the kids
clap and say in their heads,
yeah, he's right, fuck you mom.
(audience laughing)
Before you do that, I just
want you to understand,
the most fascinating thing
about a relationship,
it takes two to tango.
You can sit here as a 29-year-old
and say wait a minute,
epiphany, he's right, I'm so mad.
But you need to take
responsibility for your part.
You like all the nice
things that come along
with pleasing your parents,
there is no both ways.
So I am super passionate
because of this reason.
This is fucking crazy.
This is the remote
control of our lives now.
This is the single most
important thing in the world.
I'm literally willing to rip
off my arm and give it to you,
than give up my phone.
This is the most important.
And what's happening inside
of it, is even crazier.
Everything we know is being transformed
by the platforms inside this device.
If you are here today,
and you are not successfully
building a community
on Facebook, Instagram, Snapchat, Twitter,
you know, LinkedIn, YouTube,
if you're not successful
on one of the things
in here right now,
no matter how much money you're making,
if you are not building
a community in here,
you are becoming irrelevant.
This is the actual world,
and this is becoming secondary.
And maybe you don't like
it and it seems weird,
it doesn't change the fact,
that that's exactly what's happening.
And I highly recommend to all of you,
that if you are not putting in real hours
in figuring this out,
you are becoming unbelievably vulnerable
to whatever ambition, you sit here,
if you wanna be the Prime Minister,
if you want to sell sneakers,
if you wanna raise money
for awareness of a disease,
if you wanna sell your
restaurant, whatever it is,
if you are not producing in
this environment successfully,
you are becoming irrelevant.
And if you think about
where the world was,
just two or three or
four years ago in here,
wait till you see where it's
gonna be in two or three years.
This is just starting.
Do not get confused by the growth
over the last five years on this,
as if it's the end, or what have you.
This technology thing is just starting.
And so, I've been spending a lot of times
with the mix of the high and the low,
the ambition and the dirt,
the clouds and the dirt, right?
Why are you doing what you're doing,
and then do you know how to do it?
I'm dying to know if you're doing it
for yourself or somebody
else, I've touched on that.
Then I'm dying to, once
you know what you're doing,
for you putting in the
hours to actually do it.
The reason so many of you
are judging yourselves
for being lazy and not putting in the work
even though you keep hearing it,
is 'cause you don't
like what you're doing.
You're doing it because you
think it's gonna make money.
And so, of course, you're
not putting in the hours,
you don't like it.
You, deep down, may even
think that it's not good.
You have to figure out why.
You have to.
And then how.
And so, why this is a big conversation
and it's always been true,
the only added extra thing, for
me, to why this is important
on how and why,
is the timing and when
I'm talking about this.
If this talk was happening in 1997,
it wouldn't be as important.
Because the internet
wouldn't be at the scale
that it is today.
This is about under priced attention.
How many people have ever spent time
or paid attention to real estate?
Raise your hands, real estate.
Okay, thank you.
I think about what's happening right now
the way I think about real estate.
I don't trade beach-front
property or skyscrapers
or homes or houses, I trade attention.
To me, I know that everybody in here,
when I look around this room,
from youngsters, from this region,
to people that have been around the block
for a couple of minutes,
maybe not from this region,
when I look at all your faces,
the one thing I know that
I can talk about right here
that will matter to everybody,
whether you have money or you don't,
whether you're 20 or
you're 80, is attention.
'Cause it is the currency that we all
have to figure out how to get
to make the next thing happen.
The thing that is (audio cuts
out) globally in the world
is about attention.
The reason so much change
is happening politically
around the world, is because the attention
of the citizens of the
world have moved to this
and the newspaper, radio, television era
of the last 80 years has been disrupted,
which is why you're seeing
results in Malaysia,
the US, London, that are different
than what people expected.
They are naive and underestimating
the enormous power of this.
We, in this room, are at
a time where we, equally,
can take advantage of this.
The amount of people sitting around,
dwelling about what this is doing,
instead of realizing
that you can do something
for yourselves with it,
is fascinating to me.
My friends, this is a mindset
game, and a education game.
Everybody thinks education's important.
You hear that propaganda
all the time, right?
I agree.
I think the way education is sold
and the infrastructure
around it today is broken.
But I think education is
the most powerful thing
in the world.
I'm desperate for people in this room
to be educated on how to run Facebook ads,
it is a skill.
It's a vocational skill.
If you know how to run
Facebook ads like an expert,
in 2018, you will make a lot of money.
Not a little bit, a lot.
Yet, people hear the propaganda,
or they've run some ads unsuccessfully,
and they quit, right?
I mean, look, how many people
here, by show of hands,
and so far when I've asked for hands,
Singapore, I've gotta be honest with you,
you've been bullshitting me.
The hands have been like this.
I want high hands right now,
how many people here have run Facebook ads
and it didn't work?
Raise your hands, raise it high.
Actually, stand up, stand up, I mean it.
Please stand up.
Stand up, I see a lot
of you who haven't yet.
Stand up if you just raised your hand.
Stand up if you've run Facebook
ads and it didn't work.
I'm gonna give you two
more minutes, no lying.
Ready?
I want everybody to look
around, look around, got it?
All these people that are standing suck.
(audience laughing)
I'm kidding, I'm kidding, sit down.
But it's a very important point.
The reason I did that,
and the reason I wanted
everybody to see it,
is, I was standing too.
I have run hundreds of
thousands of dollars of ads
that didn't work.
But, I've also run hundreds
of thousands of dollars of ads
that have worked.
VaynerMedia has spent hundreds
of millions of dollars
on ads that have worked,
and hundreds of millions
of dollars that have not.
The ROI of something is based
on your talent to use it.
The ROI of a basketball for me, zero.
The ROI of a basketball for
LeBron James, $1 billion.
You have run Facebook
ads and it didn't work,
it doesn't mean that
Facebook ads don't work,
it means that you ran
Facebook ads that didn't work.
This is a very important
point, here's why.
I stand up here today, with
a man of massive regret
about one very narrow thing in business,
that ironically people cheer
for me for, but I boo myself.
Let me reenact something
that happened 20 minutes go.
I was being introduced very nicely,
and at one point, the gentleman said,
and he took his family business
from four to $60 million.
And you know what you guys did?
You clapped loud.
Let me tell you what I was doing.
I'll actually reenact
it, maybe you'll hear me.
I was right here, and he said,
and he took his business
from four to $60 million.
And you guys cheered loud, let
me tell you what I was doing.
Fuck.
(audience laughing)
Let me tell you why.
In 2001 to 2004, I ran Google
AdWords when it was new
and most people didn't understand it.
A lot of people said it wasn't working.
I know, I had a lot of ads
that didn't work either.
If this was literally 2004,
I would ask everybody here
to say stand up if you've run
Google ads and it didn't work,
and the same amount of people
would have stood up, okay?
What I know about
WineLibrary was between email
and Google AdWords, that
was a dominant reason
that I was able to take my dad's business
that didn't have a lot
of money and explode it,
because it was right.
It's the same reason
that Amazon is gonna be
one of the biggest companies in the world,
because they were the biggest
advertiser on Google AdWords
during that era.
I sit behind stage while
I get clapped, four to 60,
and my brain says it should
have been four to 250.
If I was good enough and went hard enough,
and took more money, and tried harder,
and slept less, and went harder,
it would have been four to 250.
I stand here today, knowing
that's exactly what's happening
right now on Facebook and Instagram.
That every person in this room
is gonna remember this part of the speech,
in seven years, and look back,
and 98% of you, 'cause
you're not gonna do it,
are gonna say I fucked up.
I should have listened to him.
I mean that.
I mean it.
I know it because even I
am not spending enough.
I'm spending so much, I
have a 30-person team,
I'm spending hundreds
of thousands of dollars,
and I should be spending millions.
So, please, my friends,
understand the following,
if you are not producing
content for Facebook,
for YouTube, for LinkedIn,
depending on your business,
depending on who you're trying to reach,
if you do not understand
that pictures, videos,
and written words and audio,
for seven to eight apps
on the phone is the world,
then you are vulnerable.
If you do not understand
that we are living
in a special moment in time,
because let me tell you
what's about to happen
over the next five years.
VaynerMedia's about to
become one of the biggest
marketing companies in the world,
because Coca-Cola and BMW
and GE and SAP and Nike
are all gonna hire us
over the next five years
and I'm gonna take $500
million from television
and I'm gonna put it into Facebook.
Facebook is a marketplace.
So when Facebook, you have to understand,
you're all very smart,
Facebook and Instagram.
If you wanna reach somebody
that lives in Singapore
who makes $100,000 a year,
and I wanna get in front of you,
it's gonna be in your feed.
Either you're gonna be there
or Nike's gonna be there.
Who has more money?
- [Man In Audience] Nike.
- They're gonna bid you up,
and now it costs $6 to get
in front of 1,000 people,
of which, only 13 look, 'cause
we all go fast, I got it.
But it's still $6 for 13 people.
But in four years, it's
gonna be $38 for 1,000,
and only six are gonna look at it.
My friends, this is a moment in time,
on social networks on a mobile device,
that is unparalleled in
the history of marketing.
Better than early television.
Better than early internet.
You know why?
Everybody's on it.
Everybody is on it.
From six years old to 96 years old,
there are 65-year-old men
sending text emojis right now.
Everybody, your grandparents are on it.
This has happened.
Please stop fucking around.
Please take this seriously.
Please produce content on these platforms
with everything you have.
How many people are being
successful right now
with social media
marketing and advertising?
Raise your hands.
Raise your hands high, how many people?
They're the people that
I'm most worried about.
I mean it.
The success is disguising how good it is.
I'm more worried about me than the 90%
that didn't raise their hand.
Because I've done the hard
work to figure out it's good,
and yet, I'm still not
eating enough of it.
How many people here are in
the personal brand business?
The content they put out
is them as a human being,
raise your hands.
Raise your hands high,
I just need to know.
One of the biggest things that
I wanna spend some time on
is this category, and I
think a lot more of you
should be in it.
I think everybody here
should be putting out content
as a person, and the reason they don't,
how many people here work for somebody?
Raise your hands.
Okay, so that group, I understand,
they're not in full control.
So maybe, it would be
uncomfortable for them
to put out content,
because they're worried
about their boss, makes sense.
For everybody else,
every person should be producing content,
yet of the people that are left
that didn't raise their hand,
only about 10% of that audience,
based on what I just looked
at, is putting out content.
The biggest reason most people
aren't putting out content
is they're worried about
other people's opinions
of their content.
There's a lot of people
here who stopped posting
on social media because
one anonymous person
said that they were ugly.
(audience laughing)
We're living in a time when this
is offering us the greatest
person opportunity for upside,
and the reason you're not
taking advantage of it,
is because somebody
anonymous in the Philippines
left a comment and said you were stupid.
That fucks with me.
And I need you to understand it,
and it goes back to the biggest
thing that I started with.
Which is who are you doing this for?
And are you allowing, the fact
that most people in the world
will live their entire life
valuing somebody else's opinion
of themselves more than their
own opinion about themselves,
baffles me.
I will spend the rest of
my life talking about this
and putting pressure on this conversation,
'cause it's fundamentally, the unlock.
I'm watching humans do everything,
from buying clothes to buying
homes with extra bedrooms
that they don't need,
to a million other things
that look like that,
literally trying to keep
up with the Joneses.
I don't know who these Joneses are,
but I'm gonna fucking kill them.
(audience laughing)
I mean it.
I wanna find the Joneses,
and I want to assassinate the Joneses.
Because the amount of
time and energy you spend
keeping up with the Joneses is staggering.
The respect that parents
in America and Asia
have for each other,
is the reason they're so bad at parenting.
They care about their friends'
opinions about their kids
more than they care about
their kids' happiness.
(audience applauding)
It's true.
It's crazy.
And so, that's what's breaking
down for me, everyone.
That's what's kind of top-of-mind.
I'm staggered and taken aback
by the disproportionate
abundance that we have.
I can't believe how much
opportunity you actually have.
I can't believe how simple,
I mean kids with no experience,
who just listen carefully,
a month in, which is no time at all,
are feeling the benefits
of selling stuff on these platforms.
That only speaks to me of how easy it is.
There's so much abundance.
You know, another reason.
Another reason people in this room
are not running their business
through Facebook right now
in Singapore, let's use that,
is because they have an
opinion about Facebook itself.
You have an opinion,
socially, about the phone,
and you're letting that opinion, socially,
dictate your business.
Your opinion on what kids
should be doing on their phone
is dictating how you're
thinking about your business.
Or, the fact that you
don't like seeing ads,
means you're not running them
because you don't like it.
Making decisions on you,
a focus group of one,
instead of letting the
market make decisions
is an enormous mistake.
And I see it every single day.
I love when people are like
Gary, Gary, I heard your talk,
but me and my friends,
we don't use Facebook.
I go, that's nice, Carol,
but three fucking billion people do.
My friends, the data is obvious.
The market is obvious.
What's not obvious to me,
is why you're not taking advantage of it.
What's not obvious to me, is
the majority of people here
are here because they consume my content,
you decided to come on a Saturday,
you're watching the content,
this is literally, I don't
know what you thought
that I was gonna talk about up here.
You know what's coming out of my mouth.
You know exactly what the
fuck I'm gonna talk about.
And what's interesting to
me, is why I have to do it,
because I know that maybe
you needed to see it live.
Maybe.
(audience laughing)
(audience cheering)
Maybe something happened
yesterday in your business.
The reason I continue to do what I do
is because I know it's 100% working,
and I don't know enough
about you to know which time.
Why do you think I do audio
and video and written,
I don't know how you
like to consume content,
in human form, in a
phone, in audio, in video,
in a motivational quote on Instagram,
in a fucking ridiculous snap,
I don't know how you want it,
but what I'm gonna give you is very basic.
Get your mental shit together,
and fucking to Facebook and Instagram.
(audience cheering)
It's that basic.
And so, listen.
I really appreciate that moment,
because it's the most,
kind of, honest moment,
me and you just had.
I literally don't have anything else.
(audience laughing)
Like, I can talk up here
for the next 11 hours
and I'm happy to,
but if you're asking
me what my ambition is
when I fly across the world,
it's that in nine months
I get a DM or an email
from one of you that says hey,
and by the way, this is how my life is,
so I already know what it looks like.
Hey Gary, Sally here.
I saw you in Singapore in July.
A little bit about me, I sell flowers.
I have a flower shop
and my internet business was doing okay.
I've been listening to your podcasts
for two and a half years,
before you came to Singapore,
it was the first time
that I heard you live.
For some reason I finally really listened,
and I started making 15
pictures and 20 written terms
and nine videos a week instead of one,
and you'll never believe this, Gary,
but my business has gone from
1.3 million to 6.2 million.
I just wanted to email you and thank you.
I reply, no shit, Sally, good for you.
(audience laughing)
That is why I'm here.
Because that feeling, of
actually changing somebody's life
for, in essence, free, is a
fucking feeling and a half.
And so, I'm asking, now
I'm gonna be selfish.
You don't wanna make
yourself happy for you,
'cause you've got fucked up parents, fine.
Do it for me.
(audience laughing and cheering)
And it's really interesting
why I asked you to do this.
I had an epiphany four
years ago with somebody,
depending, how many people
used to watch the wine show?
Anybody?
Thank you dude.
There we go.
So, over the last four years,
I've gotten my health
in much better shape,
and you'll never believe why.
For the first 38 years of my
life, I didn't do it for me.
I'm not good at doing things for me.
Somewhere, on a flight
from Houston to New York,
I figured out that I'm good
at being accountable to you.
I'm a good boss, I'm a good leader,
I'm a good brother, I'm good at that.
So I realized, wait a minute,
if I hire somebody full
time, who's always with me,
I'm not gonna wanna let him down.
And I literally figured out
my health, by paying somebody
$100,000 a year, just to travel,
and follow me around and be my babysitter,
and that, I didn't wanna let them down,
is why I am now in good shape.
When I said to you, if you
don't wanna do it for you,
do it for me, I'm not kidding.
You need to figure out your hack.
If you are not happy, or
satisfied in this room right now,
professionally, which is
usually because it's emotional,
if you're not in that
place, what you tend to do,
you know what's so fascinating
to me about this world
of speakers and masterminds
and courses and books
and things of that nature,
I just wanna solve the problem and move on
and never see you again.
I mean it.
It's like the business of medicine.
The answer's very simple.
You're not in the right
place in your head.
You're not.
But most people take advantage of that
and keep you on the drug forever.
I just wanna operate on you.
I just wanna look you in the face
and call out your bullshit.
Yesterday in Malaysia,
some young man said,
Gary I have a problem.
I'm too good at too many things,
so I can't pick one thing,
because I don't know which one to pick.
How do I do that?
What do I do?
And I said, well first of all you realize
that the biggest excuse in the world,
the duchiest excuse in the world,
the worst excuse in the world
is I'm too good and too many things,
because what you're actually saying
is I actually don't wanna do anything
and I wanna paint a facade to everybody
that I'm good at things,
or a perfectionist.
Gary, the reason I'm
not done with my project
is I'm a perfectionist.
Excuse, excuse, excuse.
You need to figure out
why you're making excuses.
I'll save you time.
You value somebody else's opinion
more than you value your own.
You have to figure out
how to fix that yesterday.
It is the number one cancer
in our minds, in the world.
You have to figure out,
and if you're sitting
here right now and saying
okay, that's fine Gary,
but the problem is the voice
that tells me I'm not good most
is my own voice in my
own head to me, right?
I wanna tell the people in
this room that have that issue,
that somebody put that voice in your head.
Not you.
This is a very important
point, here's why.
If I can get you past that
hurdle, you'll start doing.
If I can get you past the hurdle
of what's going on in your
head, you'll start doing.
If you start doing, at this moment,
the Facebook and Instagram
thing, you will see results.
I'm just curious what's holding you back.
I think a lot of people are held back
because they're scared to
fail in front of everybody.
Because if they fail,
then it's their loss.
The reason entrepreneurship is hard
is you have nobody to blame.
You know what, who's an employee?
Raise your hands?
You know why it's awesome
to be an employee?
You get to blame somebody else.
(audience laughing)
The reason it sucks to be an entrepreneur,
right now it's cool to be an entrepreneur
'cause there's so much money in the system
and everybody's raising capital
and you put entrepreneur
in your Instagram account
and everything looks great, right?
The problem is 98% of
people are gonna lose.
And when that loss happens, do
they have the mental strength
to deal with the judgment.
Your inability to deal with judgment,
the secrets you're hiding inside yourself
that you don't want other people to know,
is the reason you're not on the offense.
I need you to cleanse it.
And I need you to go in the offense.
And I'll tell you why I'm
passionate about it now,
and I promise you, I'm
making a prediction,
which I hate to do,
I will not be talking
about this in six years
because I'll still want
you to fix your head,
but the actions won't be as opportunistic
as they are right now.
Scale, under priced attention
comes along in cycles.
When the television took the
attention from the radio,
from the 50s and 60s and 70s,
commercials were under priced.
That's why there's so much
money in commercials now.
But it's not anymore.
For the rest of your life,
your friends, family,
kids, grandkids, are gonna
ask you about this era
of influencers and startups
and why it happened.
What was it like when all
these things were happening?
And I don't want you
sitting there with regret
that you didn't take advantage of it.
Just like I have regret in the back room,
that I didn't fully take
advantage of Google.
I took advantage of it, I did okay.
Especially for my family.
But I didn't do what I could've done.
And that is what hurts.
I know it's happening right now.
I know we're sitting through
the single biggest scaled
attention platform, the
internet, mobile devices,
social networks on the mobile devices.
Right now, I know that
every single person here
can get something from it,
and I'm trying to figure
out why you're not doing it.
Because I've told it to you
fucking 8,000 times, right?
You've heard it.
Who here has heard me say
things like this before,
even once in their lives?
Raise your hands.
I need it.
I need to know why the fuck
you're not spending money
on Facebook ads.
I need to know.
And what I know is that
some of the heady shit
that I was talking about in this talk,
the judgment of others,
the fear of failing in front of everybody,
you are acting like an entrepreneur,
but in your heart you know
you're not good at it,
and you know you're inevitably gonna fail,
and you don't wanna deal
with the ramifications
of that loss, so you're completely
half pregnant right now.
You're acting like an entrepreneur,
you're not doing anything,
and it's just gonna take some time,
and inevitably, you're gonna
start working somewhere
in six years, I don't want that for you.
I want one thing for you, health.
The second thing I want for you?
Self-awareness, do you
know who the fuck you are?
Do you know what you're good at?
These are important topics,
my friends, young or old.
You know who I fear the most?
Everybody in here who's
over 35, 40 years old.
Because they start thinking
about, it's too late,
I don't have enough time, or I already,
you're gonna live so much longer.
You're gonna live so much longer.
And so, I am desperate to understand
where you're at with your head on this
and why you're not attacking it.
Because I know flat out,
that most of the shit you hear everyday,
today, tomorrow, is just the
Band-Aid to your bullshit.
And that you really gotta figure out
what the fuck's going on inside,
because you know what to do,
the question is why are you not doing it?
My friends, the math around
becoming a human being
in current scientists
is 400 trillion to one.
The odds of you sitting here,
wearing those awesome green pants,
are 400 trillion to one.
There's nothing that will
ever happen in your life
that is more remarkable,
than the fact that you
have a fucking life.
So, since everybody here
is a fucking miracle,
wouldn't it be a good idea
to do something with it?
Like, isn't it time
now, to finally get rid
of the poison in your fucking head,
and stop worrying about other
people's judgment on you?
Let me tell you the best
part about not giving a fuck
about other people.
It's not the freedom,
it's how you get there.
Do you know how I got to a
place of not giving a fuck?
I realized everybody
else sucked at shit too.
Like, so you think your mom's so special?
She's got shortcomings somewhere else.
So, your older brother's
great at fucking school
and makes $4 million a year?
He's probably a dick-face.
(audience laughing)
Please, please, please use this keynote
as the seed to figure
out why you're acting
for other people and not yourself,
because the second you do,
the second you actually
fucking make this decision
that I'm putting a lot of pressure on you,
you'll actually start doing the things.
You know why I do things?
Do you know how hard it
was to have DRock follow me
three years ago?
Nobody was running around the world
with a person following them,
the only vloggers were
doing it first-person.
I did it 'cause I knew it was right
and where the world was going,
but the only reason I really did it
is 'cause I didn't care that you judged me
that I was douche or a jerk
for having somebody follow me.
I could never do all the things that I do
if I allowed you to judge me.
Everybody told me the internet was a fad,
everybody told me email wasn't gonna work,
everybody told me YouTube was stupid,
Twitter was really stupid,
everybody told me not to put
all my money into Facebook.
Every good thing that
has ever happened to me,
everybody told me was stupid.
So why the fuck am I
gonna listen to everybody?
And I promise you, you're
living that same life too.
Do the fucking thing that you wanna do,
stop fucking listening to other people,
start executing, get your head right,
and really get perspective.
You're a fucking miracle,
do something with it.
I fucking love you, Singapore,
stop fucking around and
take advantage of your life.
Thank you.
(audience cheering)
- [Announcer] Ladies and
gentlemen, give it up for Gary V!
(audience applauding)
(light inspirational music)
- Thank you.
Thank you.
Do something!
Do something.
- Thanks dude.
- [Gary] You want up?
- Yes!
Thank you man! (laughs)
Amazing man, amazing man.
(girl cheering)
- Groupies, get off the stage.
- Gary!
Gary!
- Reverse it.
- Gary, Gary, Gary!
- All right, all right, all right.
- You gotta take care of these.
All right, thank you.
- [Fan] Stop, stop, stop, stop. Thank you.
- Bye guys.
- Gary.
Hey Gary!
- Hello!
See you guys, thank you.
Do something!
(audience applauding)
- [Man] A good one-line.
The one-line ending.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Male Fan] Gary!
- [Female Fan] Selfie!
♪ The world's gonna know your name ♪
♪ Standing in the hall of fame ♪
(announcer speaks unclear into mic)
- [Gary] Thank you, man.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
(techno music)